let's start with alarming new
allegations against army hammer
yeah one of his accusers came forward
today with claims that are so disturbing
she broke down he abused me mentally
emotionally and sexually i thought that
she was going to kill me
the accuser who was going by her first
name effie claims the actor
raped her for four hours in 2017. she
says they had an
on and off again four-year relationship
i was constantly emotionally distressed
and i lost interest in living
her attorney gloria allred says effie
provided evidence to law enforcement and
is encouraging others to come forward
army's attorney quickly responded
calling effie attention seeking
he called all of army's interactions
completely consensual
discussed and agreed upon in advance and
mutually participatory
he also shared an explicit text message
effie allegedly sent
to the actor army's problems began
earlier this year after a series of
unverified instagram messages
allegedly sent from him leaked online
they included fantasies of rape
cannibalism
and violence the actor who left the
movie shotgun wedding with jlo
was dropped by his agent e.t last spoke
to army back in october to promote
the netflix film rebecca well first
thing let's just do a little wellness
check how's everybody doing oh you know
just living the dream i mean someone's i
don't know who knows
he played a husband trying to hide a
violent secret from his wife
she was bloated decomposing her arms
ripped off and there was nothing left of
her face